esta audiencia cuatro jornadas para la
historia de Colombia El ex líder del
temible grupo paramilitar autodefensas
Unidas de Colombia Salvatore mancuso
terminó el martes su comparecencia ante
la jurisdicción especial para la paz he
construido
esta manilla con mis manos en los
momentos de soledad en la celda
pensando en que cada uno de los puntos
de su bordado
hacen referencia al dolor al sufrimiento
al daño que causa a todos ustedes
quisiera
ofrendarlo como
como un tributo a ustedes y una muestra
de mi arrepentimiento y vergüenza Muchas
gracias
la jep es una justicia restaurativa y
transicional surgirá en 2016 tras el
acuerdo de paz entre la guerrilla de las
FARC y el estado de Colombia esta
justicia juzga es guerrilleros y
militares pero como cuenta Camilo
González pozo en France 24 mancuso
podría acogerse a esta justicia se está
considerando un caso especial de mancoso
en tanto mancuoso pretende demostrar que
él era un enlace entre el ejército y los
paramilitares para combatir a la
guerrilla y para diferentes prácticas
criminales mancoso habló de la
financiación de campañas presidenciales
como la del expresidente Álvaro Uribe de
una fosa común en Venezuela de la
llegada de los paramilitares a la
capital a petición del ex vicepresidente
Francisco santos de la declaración de
objetivo militar por parte de la policía
secreta colombiana del actual presidente
Gustavo Petro así como de vínculos con
políticos medios de comunicación y
empresas en los próximos 30 días tendrá
que sustentarlo declarado con pruebas de
ser acogido en la jep Salvatore mancuso
que espera ser deportado tras cumplir
una condena de 16 años en Estados Unidos
podría llegar al país con la libertad
condicional